what do we know about our system it
comprises eight planets
the star and a number of objects not
visible to the naked eye
but what of the resources something else
near us that deserves closer attention
like a dwarf planet for example whose
mass is a third of that of the entire
asteroid belt
an object with these properties is ceres
the second smallest dwarf planet within
the solar system after hygeia
until recent past it used to be
considered the smallest dwarf planet in
our system
series was discovered back in 1801 by
the italian astronomer giuseppe piazzi
and used to be considered a fully
fledged planet of our system for a long
time
however in 2006 this celestial body was
eventually classified as a dwarf planet
with a diameter measuring approximately
950 kilometers
ceres is the largest and the most
massive body in the asteroid belt
it also beats many satellites of giant
planets in terms of size
the diameter of enceladus for instance
is twice as small
measuring 504 kilometers
series mass accounts for almost 32
percent of the total mass of the
asteroid belt
it was possible to determine this
following the analysis of the object's
influence on other smaller objects and
the belt
according to the average value of three
most accurate estimates made by 2008
series mass is considered to be this
9.4 multiplied by 10 to the power of 20.
or 1.3 percent the mass of the moon
or else almost 6 000 times as little as
the mass of our planet
even though ceres is three and a half
times smaller than the moon
the contrast of their masses is stark
but the reason lies in the fact that
they differ in their chemical
composition
as our moon is made up mainly of hard
rocks
ceres has a spherical shape which is
untypical of most other small celestial
bodies it assumed this shape
due to the influence of its own
gravitation this is the major difference
between
series and large asteroids like palace
or juno which are not spherical in shape
the object's area is 2 849
631 square kilometers
just to compare it is slightly bigger
than argentina
unlike with other asteroids a special
feature is peculiar to series
after it assumed a spherical shape there
started gravitational differentiation of
rocks in the object's interior
briefly explained it's a process when
heavier rocks shift to the core with
lighter ones forming an outer layer
thus series came to possess a rocky core
and a cryo mantle made up of water ice
the mantle is a hundred kilometers thick
and accounts for 23 to 28 percent of the
object's mass
as well as for half its volume in
addition
it contains about 200 million cubic
kilometers of water in the form of ice
which is more than there is fresh water
on earth
speaking about the formation process of
this dwarf planet
it is assumed that ceres's core could
have been heated up as a result of
radioactive decay in the first
stage of the asteroid's life at the same
time
some part of the icy mantle may have
been in the liquid state at the time
it looks like the surface is still for
the most part covered with ice
or some kind of icy surface regolith the
question of cryovolcanism on ceres still
remains open too
following analysis of data collected by
the dawn probe
the largest mountain on series for
instance called ahuna mons
is a nicey cryo volcano this is evidence
that the dwarf planet has been
geologically active for at least the
last
billion years for all we know series may
well be active right now
seen from the earth ceres is rather dim
and its visible disk is extremely small
that is why finer details were
distinguished on it only at the end of
last century with the help of the hubble
space telescope
there is a number of light and dark
spots to be seen on the asteroid's
surface
which appear to be craters
the brightest one of these has been
dubbed piazzi
probably this spot is a crater spilling
some of the icy mantle or perhaps
showing a cryovolcano
further observation of the object in the
infrared range revealed the average
surface temperature
which is 167 degrees kelvin or 106
degrees celsius below
zero thanks to the observations of the
dwarf planet and the radio spectrum
it was ascertained that series's surface
is quite smooth
come to think of it it is hardly
surprising as the icy mantle should be
quite elastic
telescopic investigation has remained
the only observation method employed to
study series until
2015 thus water vapor clouds around the
object were spotted in january 2014
thanks to the herschel infrared space
telescope
this is how ceres came to be the fourth
celestial body in the solar system with
registered water activity
the other three are enceladus europa and
of course
our earth the dawn interplanetary space
probe launched in 2007
heralded the most momentous stage in
studying the dwarf planet
having drifted in vesta's orbit for a
while dawn proceeded to make the
acquaintance of ceres
and on the 13th of january 2015 it
captured the first
detailed images of the asteroid surface
on the 8th of february the probe was
just some 118 000 kilometers away from
the object
heading towards it at a speed of 360
kilometers per hour
on the 18th and 25th of february 2015
nasa published detailed pictures of the
dwarf planet
where two bright white spots are clearly
seen
the spots were later identified as
supposedly the chemical element
sodium carbonate also known as soda
dawn went on to enter the asteroids
orbit on march the 6th
where it was to stay for the next 16
months to carry on observation
it is in this period that it was able to
take images of the puzzling white spots
and to this day these photos are the
best we have of them
the probe's mission was over on june the
30th 2016.
the data beamed back to the earth helped
estimate the dwarf planet's mass and
size and also provide hard evidence of
there being water ice on the planet's
surface
and it is likely to be found inside the
craters
634 such craters have been spotted in
the northern polar area of ceres
10 of which contain deposits of bright
material
ice formation has been spectroscopically
identified in one of them
spectra in 2015 revealed no water
but revealed presence of hydroxyl rich
materials and a somewhat weaker streak
of ammonium it is likely to be
ammonia-rich clay
where water is chemically bound and
comes forth as hydroxyl
thanks to the data revealed by the dawn
probe it was possible to make certain
conclusions about the craters
since the number of large craters is
smaller than expected
it is logical to assume that the surface
undergoes gradual changes
as a result of all studies that have
been carried out it is suggested that
water vapor is likely to account for 20
to 30 percent of series
apart from that various hydrous minerals
and substances may be found in the
surface composition
carbonates and clays rich in iron
ceres hasn't been discovered to have any
moons
based on observations using the hubble
telescope it is safe to say that even if
there are any
moons they cannot be over 20 kilometers
in diameter
but be it as it may the history of
studying this space object
isn't over yet in the next decade the
chinese national space administration
or cnsa is planning to take soil samples
from the dwarf planet's surface
series is often associated with another
large object in the asteroid belt
the celestial body in question is called
vesta and is considered to be the
largest
known asteroid in terms of size and mass
in fact vesta is clearly seen even with
the naked eye from our planet's surface
its parameters are 578 by 560 by 458
kilometers
were it not so asymmetrical it would
also be classified as a dwarf planet
as it would then qualify to be called
one according to the updated
classification of the solar system
objects
the combined mass of western palace
another large asteroid
is half that of ceres
at the same time vesta is 25 heavier
than
palace the surface temperature investor
fluctuates between 106
and 3 degrees celsius below zero
and here is a picture of both vesta and
series taken by the curiosity mars rover
in 2014
several decades ago an object like ceres
would pose
quite a riddle for scientists today
however
we're able to speak with relative
certainty about its
makeup chemical composition and history
of formation
and now a question to you guys what are
your impressions after watching this
video
what other little known objects of our
system would you like to find out about
space objects like that are silent
keepers of various facts as yet
unaccounted for
and we'd be happy to bring you up to
speed i hope you appreciate this project
of ours and hit the like button
subscribe and help our channel grow as
the most exciting things
are still up ahead let's keep in touch
[Music]
foreign